Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning, Ruffians!
It's our 80th episode today!
And we still doing!
80th episode at 8am!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Are we sure though?
I'm pretty sure.
Yes.
80 already?
I know, right?
I mean, we do have enough.
Christmas.
We had the FUWAMOCO Morning specials, but... Specials!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 80th episode!
BAU BAU!
Hey, it's already the 80th episode!
Somehow, we're here at 80 now!
It's not our age.
Not our age.
No, we're much older than that.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians,
It's our 80th episode today, but... Oh!
Hatsuriyatai!
I'm gonna explain!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us.
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag... What?
That's not a hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag.
What's the thing you hold stuff in, Moco-chan?
Plastic bag.
Hashtag.
Say it again?
Plastic bag.
Hashtag.
Huh.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Maybe not as good as a plastic bag.
But it looks sort of similar.
A Ruffian spotted Pero again.
And Moco-chan, you think Pero is a... He looks kind of like a plastic bag.
But the plastic bag's better?
Can't hold stuff with Pero.
Let's see where he was spotted!
De-den!
What does this mean, Moco-chan?
Was he spotted nowhere?
De-den!
I feel...
Just because you're here, a bit of a vision.
What's going on here?
When I look at Pero like that, I'm a bit concerned.
The look in his eyes.
Straight up, there's a Ruffian.
Were you able to pick up the package?
What was in it?
Maybe our debut merch?
That would be nice, you know?
We hope you're able to get it with no problems.
But, well... Moco-chan.
That's the thing.
Well, we were told that this Ruffian hasn't tweeted since they uploaded this photo.
Oh.
They might be in trouble.
If you're doing okay, Ruffian, give us a sign!
I didn't know that picking up packages could be this dangerous.
Be careful, Ruffians, okay?
You have to be on the lookout.
Yeah.
Okay.
Safety's important.
BAU BAU.
Got it?
We want you to be safe.
Yeah.
As demon guards, we want you to be safe.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we have some amazing news for you!
Adventrix too!
Because, well, Nerissa and Biboo, they're gonna be releasing their first cover song together!
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be on Nerissa's channel and it'll be premiering tomorrow on Tuesday at 5pm PT or 10am JST.
We're so excited!
We're gonna be singing the song "OTOMEROID"!
It's cute, so shiny.
You know what I really like?
Both Nerissa and Biboo, they have very different voices and personalities.
I think, you know, it really works so well because they're so different, you know?
Right, right!
Yeah, I really love that about Advent, right?
We're all so different, but you know, we come together to make a very special unit!
Please make sure to check it out, Ruffians!
Okay!
Only one more sleep until it premieres.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know, this week is
BAU!
She's doing a pause for a cause charity scheme to raise money for cat protection in the UK!
BAU BAU!
And well, I think you know how much we love cats, right Ruffians?
And, Calli-senpai does too!
So she invited us to be a part of it!
But you know, our demon dog paws will be put to good use!
Paws for a Cause!
We'll be taking a look all together at some of your adorable pets with the hashtag #FUWAMOCALLIPETS.
Not just dogs this time.
Cats.
It's safe in the cheeks.
Just a little.
But we're also going to be playing a Mario Party together with her and another lovely VTuber named Milky Queen!
And it's the first time for all of us!
We're really excited because Milky Queen was how we discovered VTubers first!
We really love her!
We're really looking forward to having such a silly time.
A Mario Party!
Kinda brings something different out in FUWAMOCO, right?
We've been trying to get Advent to play with us, but... It hasn't happened.
Please join us and Calli-senpai for a pause for our first charity stream tomorrow, okay?
Let's all put all our paws towards a good cause.
BAU BAU!
It'll be cute.
I'm looking forward to seeing everyone's cute pets!
Right!
Especially the cats.
Please, please send us your cats, okay?
Physically, not just photos.
Yeah.
Physically.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, I wonder... Did you see this?
They're cool, but...
But Marine-senchou-senpai drew us an illustration!
Just for us!
Just for us, okay?
She drew Moco-chan here by hand with a mechanical pencil.
Isn't it adorable?
Adorable, huh?
Yeah.
Ah, well, you know, Marine-senchou-senpai, she said that we're cute, too.
But she said that she especially likes how Moco-chan, how you speak.
I don't really know what she's talking about too much, though.
I know the Ruffians said on my birthday that you like the way I speak, too.
But... I don't know.
I don't know.
True.
Agreed 100%.
Huh?
Like, BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Ore mo!
Morning senchou!
Ahoy!
That sounds weird.
Sounds a little different.
It does!
It sounds a little different.
Mococo!
Huh?
Hi!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
I hear it.
I hear it, Ruffians.
Anyways, Marin-senchou-senpai's illustration is now up on our fridge.
Our fridge is a very special spot, okay Ruffians?
It's not just the fridge, okay?
Because you know,
The fridge is where all your food is.
And whenever you need to have food, which is multiple times a day, you look at the fridge.
It's a special, special spot.
That's why it's special, because there's food in it!
And because there's special things on the front, too.
Well, we really love it that much, okay?
BAU BAU!
Alright, we got illustrations from Calli-senpai, Mikocchi-senpai, Marine-senchou-senpai.
We're gonna have to start doing more drawings ourselves, but... But, well...
Ruffians.
We have a little bit of an apology to make.
You know, yesterday we had a homework day, right?
On our schedule it's a homework day.
Yeah.
And you know, we said we're going to work really, really hard, right?
Get our homework done.
Yeah.
Well, actually... That's not what happened at all!
We're so, so, so Ruffians!
There were alarms, and by the time we woke up, it was already way dark out.
Really, really dark.
Yeah.
You know, we even would have slept through our regular meeting time with Mine-chan!
But, luckily it was cancelled yesterday.
Yeah.
So...
We didn't get as much homework done as we had planned.
Yeah.
But, but, we did get a lot of rest.
Which is really important too, right?
Yeah.
It's kind of an important part of our duty as Demon Guide Dogs, too, right?
You too, Ruffians.
Right?
That's why I always say right, okay?
So make sure you rest when you need to rest, okay?
But, uh... Now we have to run, run, run, okay?
And, you know, uh... Well, uh...
And yes, our sleepiness.
Our soupy brain-ness.
It also caused something else to happen.
Yeah.
Ruffians.
I don't know how many hours we slept, but because of it, well, there's been a bit of a misunderstanding.
Somehow, somewhere, many times over, we misunderstood the time that we would be collabing with Koe-senpai.
You know, we even go from the date and time with her.
You know, somehow we just really got confused with time zones.
You know, we're used to it.
We've been doing this forever with no issues.
Why now all of a sudden?
Must be the spring.
Yeah.
Anyways, we now have five different things on Valentine's Day.
This is our updated schedule.
We have a karaoke stream together with Kawaii Senpai first thing in the morning at 6am.
A little early FUWAMOCO Morning.
And then a collab cover song releases at 7AM on Kuro-senpai's channel.
And then over on our channel, well, it's FUWAMOCO Morning at 8AM.
Then, a super special choose-your-own-adventure Valentine's Day stream at 6PM.
And finally, our members-only version Valentine's Day stream.
Yeah.
It's just a bit busy.
Just a bit.
Yeah, but between all the prep for the Valentine's Day stream and all our plans, I don't really know when we'll be sleeping, but we know one thing, Ruffians!
We're going to have an amazing Valentine's Day together with all of you!
Please join us and let's have the best Valentine's Day all together, okay?
Midnight now.
BAU BAU!
You have to be there for the Valentine's Day stream, okay?
You have to.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Moco-chan, do you know what day of the week it is?
No, I can't remember anymore.
Ruffians!
Do you know what day of the week it is?
It's Monday, the first day of the week, which means Moco-chan is gonna challenge herself to something new?
New question mark.
Which is... Overcoming her dislike of natto!
It's now been very many weeks now.
And Moco-chan's been doing her best to overcome her dislike of natto, which is a Japanese breakfast food, a very popular breakfast food.
That's fermented beans.
And it's really good for you!
And I like it a lot.
I have it every day.
It's really good for you, good for your tummy.
Vitamins you can only get from natto.
Which, you know, it's interesting, Moco-chan, because sometimes we hear that from Ruffians that there's a vitamin that you can only get from FUWAMOCO.
If you think about it, we're like the Ruffians, natto, then, huh?
So... Ruffians!
And we are natto-ers!
So then, Moco-chan, today you have to be a bit of a cannibal.
What?
And eat the...
The bean version of FUWAMOCO.
Got it!
Understood?
Yeah.
Moco-chan!
It's all ready!
Why are you making ghost sounds like that?
Last time, Moco-chan, you ate two beans, right?
I did!
Yeah!
But I don't have any stuff for this!
Stuff?
Sesame oil.
Well, I said no to the sesame oil today because I want Moco-chan to improve, Ruffians.
But I did say yes to soy sauce.
I don't want soy sauce!
I want soy sauce later.
I don't want sesame oil.
Moco-chan, do you want the soy sauce?
No crutches!
Crunches?
No, no crutches.
Soy sauce, no?
Ruffians, look at the design!
Wait, I'm gonna pick up a bean and put a drop on the bean.
You have to make sure you aim proper.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
I haven't picked it up!
Let me choose the bean!
Choose faster!
It's stringy!
Okay, one second, one second!
Okay, okay, okay.
Drop of soy sauce.
Just a drop, just a drop.
Guess that was your best attempt, huh?
I see you on there.
Here we go!
Okay, Moco-chan, you can do it!
No countdown this time!
3, 2, 2!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
Don't make that face!
You got it!
Oh, she's chewing it!
Yum, yum, yum!
You did it!
You did it, Moco-chan!
I just tasted soy sauce.
Okay, let's do a second one then.
It tastes different.
But I feel like last time when we put soy sauce on it, it was worse.
Much, much worse.
No!
And to be honest, I totally saw the soy sauce completely miss the bean and just get on the chopsticks.
What does it taste like?
It maybe tastes like natto?
No.
Okay.
We're gonna do a second bean!
Let's see if it's any better.
Could you be getting used to the taste, Moco-chan?
You chewed it!
There's no way you didn't taste it.
Okay, go!
Go!
It's in there!
It's in!
Oh!
Oh, you're chewing it!
Can you do a third?
Oh my gosh, Ruffians!
It's today's the day!
Okay Moco-chan, third bean, let's do it!
Are you gonna take two?
Two beans at once?
They're stuck together.
You can do it, you can do it.
Four beans.
Four beans today!
No.
Keep going, keep going!
Let's do three.
This is a big one though, okay?
It's a big one.
Okay, I did it.
Three beans.
A little soy sauce.
Oh, oh, I missed.
I missed it.
There we go.
Is that enough for that?
That's good.
Beautifully covered in a blanket of soy sauce.
I don't know about that.
I have the natto from Tochigiza.
Okay, okay.
It's very enjoyable.
Countdown!
Three!
Two!
One!
Okay, okay.
Some strings, but it's okay.
Moco-chan's a pro.
Oh, except for the face is getting a bit more intense this time.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Another bean!
Another!
Yeah!
Another bean!
I can see it on your face.
You still have so much room to go.
I can see it.
I know all the faces Moco-chan makes when she eats natto.
And she has so much more natto she can eat today.
You're just pouring it all over.
Fourth bean!
Here we go!
This one has quite a good blanket of soy sauce on it.
It's gone.
Oh my goodness!
It tastes different to me.
Four beans!
It tastes... It tastes very sweet.
Akemoco-chan, you're gonna go for your fifth bean.
No soy sauce!
Yeah!
No soy sauce.
No soy sauce for you.
My gosh, this is a miracle, Ruffians!
It's a Valentine's Day miracle!
Oh my gosh!
I didn't eat the natto just for you, okay?
Moco-chan is becoming unstoppable!
Natto machine!
Okay, Moco-chan!
Go!
No soy sauce!
A raw, straight natto bean.
She chewed it!
Oh my gosh!
Ruffians!
Are you just... What's the situation here, Moco-chan?
Are you just... I don't know.
Wow.
I don't know what to say.
Okay, I need to test you.
You need to take up at least three at once.
Three at once?
And then this could be over.
I don't even know how many beans I'm eating then.
That's five beans you've eaten.
Five?
Yeah, that's five.
Today you have five!
You have five today!
Three at once, we're gonna do it.
Three at once?
Yeah.
And then you can finish your meal.
Oh my gosh.
There's more sticky stuff between them when there's many of those.
Yeah.
That's the good part.
You have two beans!
One more!
I don't think I can pick up three at once.
Do you want your record to be... Eight beans?
Or do you want it to be seven beans?
I think eight is a better number.
I don't know.
8 bins to infinity!
Right!
8 bins on 80.
Right.
That makes sense, but I feel like 3 at once is really pushing it, Ruffians!
You can do it!
Do you want a bit of soy sauce for this one?
Yeah.
There you go.
Just a little bit of a blanket.
Okay, this is 3 at once now!
Okay!
Okay! 3! 2! 1!
You did it, Moco-chan!
I did it!
Let me see.
I'm so proud of you, FUWAMOCO-chan!
BAU BAU!
I did it, okay?
I ate eight beers!
What was my previous record?
Three.
BAU BAU!
Okay, Moco-chan!
I feel confused.
Yeah, that's almost a whole spoonful!
Wow.
You can eat natto?
No.
You can't?
No!
Wow.
Ruffians!
Remember, it's the start of a new week, so you can challenge it!
You can do the thing!
Moco-chan, she almost ate eight beans!
That's like a sixteenth of the pack.
That's pretty good.
BAU BAU!
Good job, Moco-chan!
I thank you farmers in Tochigi for making delicious natto.
BAU BAU!
This week, you know, is Cali-senpai's paws for the cause charity.
But let's take a look at our Doggie of the Day.
Doggie of the Day is...
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Big, big eyes.
I love you!
So cute!
Very cute!
Nose too!
Big booba boy!
Well, Kota's a very good boy.
He loves to play and cuddle and sleep.
All good things, huh?
How does Kota BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
You can see all the sweetness behind those puppy dog eyes.
But Ruffians, do you notice something?
Yeah.
You see that there?
We noticed.
Cora!
Cora has the pick of any shoe to chew on there.
A lot of shoes!
Yeah.
And not a single one has been bitten.
Not a single one!
Right?
What a good doggy!
You are, Cora!
BAU BAU!
Good self-control.
Not one!
BAU BAU!
And next for our today I went on a walk, we have De-den!
It's a beautiful day!
It really makes you want to go like dance and sing and be swirly about in the shining green field.
Did you do that?
I feel like
You know, it would make sense if there was a fuzzy cow or two.
And I could jump on the cow, see what happens.
Yeah!
But, you know, this kind of beautiful day really makes me so excited for spring!
Right!
Just around the corner, how rough it is!
Think of all those wonderful walks waiting for us then, huh?
I can't wait!
BAU BAU!
Oh, and next for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Oh!
Hi, Fuwawa-chan, uh, Moco-chan!
Hello!
I have a question for Moco-chan.
You said you really like succulents, and you have some plants already.
Is there an occasion why you started to care for them, and what is your favorite kind?
Your morning programs always make my day!
BAU BAU!
Wow, wow, Moco-chan.
Originally, I saw succulents online.
And, I don't know, I wanted to care for something.
I guess, I guess I felt a bit lonely.
I wanted some friends.
I know they don't die easily!
They won't leave you alone!
And I...
I don't know.
They look really fun.
There's a lot of different types.
I know.
They're very resilient, but also kind of particular about stuff.
Kind of like me.
And, I don't know.
I like taking care of them.
Although mine are very, very thirsty right now.
But they aren't dead!
Are they being taken care of?
They are being taken care of.
I wish I could get more light because the more light that some of them have then they turn
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
We have another theme coming up today.
What theme is that, Moco-chan?
We have White Album!
De-den!
We're playing White Album.
If you haven't heard of it before, it's a visual novel that we really, really like.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Things get dramatic.
You know and well especially with her famous senpai also an idol she took us out on a date and then we saw we might have seen Yuki and her producer also out for a date business meeting date and then you know Yuki's manager trying to start a
BAU BAU!
And for our schedule, well, as you know, we messed up.
We messed up!
So please make sure that you take a good look at the updated version of our schedule.
You can also find it on the YouTube community page and Twitter.
And yes, let's have a lot of fun while surviving an extra special Valentine's Day together.
Make sure, you know, our special Valentine's Day stream makes sure you're there.
You have to be there, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 80th episode!
Thank you for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning here with us.
Lending us your Doggie of the Day and letting us know what walks you've been on.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Cori!
BAU BAU!
Doya Doya.
Maiko.
BAU BAU!
Copterp.
Yahiro.
BAU BAU!
Mr. Snap.
Elly.
BAU BAU!
BAU!
Taiyo Salad!
BAU BAU!
Potato Source!
Tea!
BAU BAU!
Credit!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!